Xenoblade Chronicles X let's all do it
it actually not to cross cross cross I
missed it works right across the power
of Christ compels you to play this video
game which came out in Europe back in
April no Japan my friend sorry Japan by
April and it's coming out and this month
or December third awesome when's our of
you gonna be up November 30th awesome
but you guys have been playing the game
for a little while and we're gonna ask
you without getting into the sort of
critical assessment area and all about
this game so for those who don't know
zen evade chronicles as a series i guess
what is cross exactly so Xenoblade
Chronicles X cross everyone i pronounced
it is like kind of a pseudo follow-up to
the the wii title Xenoblade Chronicles
they share some similarities in terms of
mechanics but in terms of the world
everything like that very different
games and it takes place in a very big
world this new one people liking it too
bigger than the witcher Skyrim and
fallout combined yeah yeah and a truly
open world like it's one of these things
where if you look somewhere you can go
see you can go there right pretty much
if you can figure out a way to jump all
the way up onto something and you can
pretty much climb anything yeah or swim
or swim too yeah excellent it's huge
it's really big tell us about the world
it's our Earth's been gone blowing up to
your crotch lon messed up man yeah sorry
my voice is a little weird to Kate skip
are wondering why anyway so you yeah the
spaceship left Earth and then got in the
middle of an alien conflict conflict
crash landed on this planet and and
you're sort of their scouting the planet
just to figure out how to make a life
for everyone who is part of New Los
Angeles which is a section of the
massive spaceship that guy man we just
destroyed old Los Angeles why would you
make a new one yeah of all the cities um
yeah where's yeah no no that's they just
left effects I think me los angeles is
not yeah selenium um yeah this is so
this this is the map and all those
little towers are like you go when you
put down a probe which means you've
effectively colonized or surveyed that
area okay so what you're doing is you're
calling
using this world and you're collecting
samples picking up remnants the whole
big thing is like you are part of a
group of people that is that are trying
to find the rest of the people like
everyone else is in like cryostasis or
something yeah the ship exploded right
so it's like all over the planet there's
some there's some people that are in
cryostasis so you have to go find them
and that yeah that's totally part of it
the no one cool thing this game does
though right like you explore as part of
the story like for quests but as you lay
down those probes as Alexa was
describing their those actually play a
bigger picture in terms of like loot and
stuff like that so you can set these
probes two different things one of the
things they can do is mine hmm as you
mind and collect this resource I believe
it's called Mourinho yeah yeah what you
then do is you can use that to invest in
different weapons and armor
manufacturers and get access to new loot
so the more you explore the more ability
you have to unlock new gear not just by
finding it what you do but also by
investing in companies who develop new
stuff what they're showing right now on
the screen are the mechs got da and the
Japanese version they were called dolls
now they're called skills because
because you know whatever and also play
with dolls right and these are a really
big part of the game but they don't I'm
about 25 hours in and okay and I think
I'm close to the point where maybe I'm
going to unlock them right so this is a
game which is pushing the like 70-80
aramark yeah it's a very big game and I
kind of liken it to an MMO it doesn't
play like an MMO but what it does do is
offer a huge amount of quests and
sometimes these are easy to find excuse
me other times like a Xenoblade
Chronicles on the wii u have to find
people in a specific part of town at a
specific time of day and have talked to
someone else oh wow like very specific
oh all right let's give you respite for
a second Alexa tell me about the
question is like main quest stuff this
affinity quest which are about getting
sort of extra people on your team or
yeah there's just so much crap to deal
with in this game and I both love it and
hate it there's a you so you you pick
which you pick a job there's like I
think it's 7-10 something like that
different job classes and they
have different things like okay you're
going to focus on colonizing new areas
you're going to focus on finding people
that are in cryostasis or you're going
to focus on killing big animals and you
join that group and then you have a
separate level of whatever you're doing
in that group and then you have your
personal level then you have your
affinity levels and you have your field
level don't forget your blade level your
blade level here whatever job you have
and then you have your field level and
there's your archaeological skills your
mechanical skills and your something
biological skills and all of these level
up separately but together and sometimes
you can't do something if a certain
level isn't high enough because you need
to get another level high enough you
can't level up that a lot of lighthouses
level that person management character
management quest management it's I'd say
quest management world management if you
if you play it intelligently when you
figure out how everything ties together
it actually works pretty smoothly across
the board like you understand how one
thing affects another and so on it's a
little bit difficult to understand at
first read the manual get it on my
advice to you know the games coming
manuals anymore what this we don't have
the retail like physical version of this
game we have the disc but the in-game
manual okay where you find it and it's
very helpful actually eyes yeah um or
you could play it dumbly like me I
refuse to read the manual I'm trying to
figure out all that on my own yeah and
it is so much to take in I mean I like
really thick meaty JRPGs but this is a
JRPG ass junior yeah it's crazy it looks
good tell us all about the worlds the
idea of an open sort of planet where you
can travel anywhere is seems very
appealing to me and tell me about the
world in its inhabitant since monsters
before you so the world again is huge
and it is pretty much wilderness you
will maybe encounter some you know
organic I don't I don't wanna spoil
anything anyway so yeah anything big
wide world with a huge scale like big
mountains big cliffs big animals big
bodies of water baby animals it's huge
and and at times it's it's really
impressive at least to me and it's not
one of those games where the world is
big but it's not interesting like the
way the landscaped is is shaped and the
way things sort of interplay like the
water with the mountains and stuff it's
actually done really well like there was
a lot of attention to detail to give
these
is a unique feel beyond just this has
sand versus grass and so on and it yeah
and it's really big and you can pretty
much go anywhere I think there are some
contents that are disconnected that
maybe you need the scale to get to I'm
not positive but yeah I mean you're able
to wander into areas like one she was
telling me about a place called oblivia
it's sort of connected to the first
content you start on but when you first
get there at least when I did there were
lightning storms mm-hmm and I was slowly
having my health depleted and it was
like the hell apparently you need to
have a lightning sort of debuff thing
but at the same time if you wait the
time of day changes the weather changes
once the weather changes and you can go
in there just fine so it's it's a
massive living world and there are
creatures that will always be a grow
always out to get you there are
legendary versions of creatures always
be Agra ya know if you grow and you have
creatures that are just huge
monstrosities it's like you know
Bulbasaur the elder level like 9-930 or
something they difficult fights uh lots
of difficult fights it's easy to kind of
get yourself caught in line of sight of
an enemy that's too high level alright
so part of this game is being aware of
your environment as well and traversing
it carefully in doing so and and yeah
I'm really liking the loop right now of
questing and getting loot and leveling
up so that's been great like that a lot
cool does it feel I have you played
previous games in series Alexa yeah yeah
I played the hell out of xenoblade
chronicles the last one yeah that was
really great does it feel like very
similar to it yeah cuz it has like the
art system which is I guess like the
spells and the different attacks like
it's a very similar combat system but
everything else is just like really
different the quest structure is is
similar the thing I was describing
earlier with like the way I fitting the
missions work you know and like getting
to know people and doing that sort of
thing it's really there for the hardcore
folks because yeah fans of the genre
yeah yeah can you play this not as a
hardcore is it a blade fan yeah I mean
this is only the second game in the
series and it's not really connected to
the prior one beyond mechanics um can't
play just as a non hardcore video game
fan cuz this seems like it's the type of
game that requires quite a lot of you in
terms of time commitment and the effort
this is definitely a video games min
video game in again great law honestly
read the manual like that's just my
advice like we're doughnut struggle or
don't struggle but that's the choice
you're deciding to make on your own yeah
I'm playing it dumbly as opposed to in
dylan's you should do like a to take
review on this one the manual versus the
Naamah I'm still running in like Kofi
Morkel versus education is a 70-200 our
game what we've heard so excellent ends
a lot of time under he will be off last
day of this month last day this month
awesome yeah thanks so much guys coming
on and explaining to me the terrified as
if there wasn't you know I I just have
all this free time there's not enough
open-world games out there not get out
this year right 2015 my goodness and
maybe one to get and your Christmas
stocking let us know if you are going to
pick it up later this year or if you're
already in Japan and you just halfway
through at this stage in the comment box
below go get back